wir haben ende november und ich werde in
diesem video sieben tage lang draußen in
einem see eisbaden geht ganz kurz vorweg
extreme momentan im dezember jeden tag
wenn ihr also dabei sein wollt klickt
auf den link in der video beschreibung
oder auf dem youtube link um die
highlights zu sehen wir sehen uns im
stream oder auf dem anderen kanal in
einem meiner letzten videos ging es
schon darum dass sich deutlich
unzufrieden mit mir über die letzte zeit
geworden bin und ich immer wieder
auswege suche wie ich das verbessern
kann in dem ersten video aus der reihe
habe ich dann geatmet das hat eine menge
spaß gemacht und hat auch schon einiges
gebracht aber zu dieser atemtechnik
gehört bei wim hof auch noch etwas
anderes nämlich das eis war im prinzip
ist das auch eigentlich das womit wim
hof berühmt geworden ist da hat er seine
rekorde aufgestellt das macht ihn
besonders und der bleibt in so eiskalt
und wasser oder wirklich von eiswürfeln
umgeben für mehrere minuten
das werde ich in diesem video nicht
machen aber ich werde jeden tag eisbahn
gehen und schauen ob das eine
veränderung auf meine gesundheit hat und
ob das eine veränderung vielleicht sogar
auf mein arbeitsalltag und meine
konzentrationsfähigkeit usw hat denn das
verspricht diese methode ich werde in
diesem video schauen ob diese praktik
mir dabei helfen kann mein immunsystem
zu stärken meinen gesundheitssystem zu
stärken und zum anderen ob sie mir dabei
hilft meinen inneren schweinehund zu
überwinden so dass sich die scheiß
aufgaben die mich so jeden tag
konfrontieren oder die ich dich zu
erledigen habe dass ich dir einfach
besser machen kann und somit insgesamt
gesünder und glücklicher wirkte habe ich
das gesagt echt ja mein
gesundheitssystem ich bin habe ein
eigenes gesundheitssystems iren sparen
ist mein gesundheitsminister was aber an
diesen ganzen versprechen dran ist
werden wir jetzt herausfinden viel spaß
ich will hier gar nicht so lange hin und
her machen ich habe michael schon dafür
entschieden das jetzt für die nächsten
sieben tage zu machen
deswegen werde ich mich jetzt einfach
umziehen und reingehen unter beobachtung
der
die zu meiner rechten zu meiner linken
und direkt vor mir sind also meine nase
läuft schon und ich muss ehrlich sagen
das ist wirklich jetzt schon hier so an
der frischen luft arschkalt aber ich
ziehe durch und wir bekommen
kein scheiß ich bin davon ausgegangen
dass es kalt ist aber dass es so kalt
ist damit hätte ich niemals gerechnet es
war wirklich unglaublich und ich habe
mich komplett verschätzt wer hätte damit
ende november berechnen können
heute ist so gestört kalt ich hoffe man
sieht das aber ich bin am dampfen ich
fühle meine haut nicht mehr jetzt new
york ich spüre einfach meine haut nicht
mehr was irgendwie komisch ist seitdem
ich aus dem wasser raus bin habe ich
kein einziges mal gefahren also wirklich
keine sekunde
ich glaube der körper arbeitet halt
einfach so stark dagegen und fängt an
würfel in schwung zu bringen und den
körper so warm zu machen in dieser
situation in der es im wasser so extrem
kalt ist das einfach nachher die
außentemperatur die nicht so kalt ist
wie es wasser überhaupt kein problem
mehr ist weil der körper hat probiert da
komplett gegen zu arbeiten und
vielleicht irgendwas freisetzt den in
der stresssituation oder so dem tag an
so einem see gestartet zu haben niemand
um einen rum außer so ein paar angler
tut schon gut und wir haben jetzt nicht
mal 10 uhr ich bin immer noch komplett
pünktlich im büro kann anfangen zu
arbeiten aber habe irgendwie das gefühl
schon was geschafft zu haben oder
zumindest irgendwas für mich gemacht
sondern man könnte sie auch fragen wie
ich darauf komme das alles zu machen und
ich glaube darauf habe ich eine ziemlich
genaue anfang anfang des jahres habe ich
stets meine kennengelernt ein wirklich
sehr besonderer youtuber der sich
eigentlich im outdoor und survival
kümmert wir waren gemeinsam auf madeira
und was ihnen von uns unterschieden hat
war dass der abend ein bier getrunken
hat dass er nicht bis 1 uhr oder zwei
uhr nachts wach war sondern früher
schlafen gegangen ist und dafür auch
drei stunden vor uns aufgewacht ist und
gerade also new york der ist wirklich
einfach so den kompletten berg in
madeira hoch gewandert durchs gestrüpp
und ich habe mich gefragt wie kommt das
wie kann das sein dass jemand so einen
inneren drang hat so ein feuer hat über
seine eigenen grenzen hinweg zu gehen
und sich immer wieder solchen
situationen solchen extremsituationen
auszusetzen
und vielleicht ist das der grund warum
ich das hier jetzt auch probieren aber
damit nicht nur ich verstehen kann was
fritz meinecke antreibt und was ihn zu
der person macht die er ist bin ich zu
ihm gefahren und habe ein porträt mit
ihm gedreht für ein neues format was
nächste woche raus kommt oder in den
nächsten wochen irgendwann vergesse ich
den kanal zu abonnieren damit du das
nicht verpassen
an tag 2 hat sich zu tag eins quasi gar
nichts verändert ich bin kein bisschen
besser mit der kälte klar gekommen es
war genauso kalt wie am tag eins gab es
aber geschafft ein bisschen länger
auszuharren und auch im wasser ein
bisschen ruhiger zu werden also einfach
nicht so superschnell zu atmen und mich
einfach darauf einzulassen und ruhig zu
werden außerdem habe ich angefangen die
zeit am see morgens einfach ein bisschen
besser zu genießen und bin ein bisschen
weiter rumgelaufen und das hat echt gut
getan also gute abwechslung zu meinem
normalen stadt alltag und kein scheiß an
tag 2 habe ich schon resultate gemerkt
ich bin ins büro bekommen habt ihr
diesen ganzen träsch rumstehen sehen der
mich seit mehreren wochen abgefuckt hat
ich habe es immer vor mir hergeschoben
diesen ganzen karton kram und so weg zu
räumen
und dann hab ich gedacht es ist
überhaupt kein problem ich kümmere mich
jetzt einfach rum und habe das sofort
geregelt und dann habe ich verstanden
woran das liegt wenn ich mich morgens
schon so einer situation aussetzen und
so über meinen inneren schweinehund
hinweg gehe dann werden die scheinbar
großen probleme die man so über den tag
hat also nicht so als wären jetzt diese
kartons weg zu bringen
wir sind problem aber so sachen die
einen einfach abhaken die man vor sich
herschiebt sind einfach kein problem
mehr man erledigt sie einfach und hat
dann ruhe dann hatte ich gehofft dass
sich über die tage weniger problem damit
habe ins kalte wasser zu gehen dass es
sich weniger kalt anfühlt weil man sich
dran gewöhnt oder so und das ist nicht
passiert ich glaube man wird sich egal
wie lange man das macht nicht an die
kälte gewöhnen und genau das macht auch
den reiz aus was sich aber für ein
riesen unterschied gemerkt habe ist dass
ich mir viel weniger gedanken darüber
gemacht habe ich wusste ich werde das
machen also habe ich nicht gewartet das
wasser wird nicht wärmer die briefe die
im stapel im büro liegen arbeiten sich
nicht von alleine ab ich habe mich
mental einfach darauf eingestellt die
sachen einfach zu machen ohne darüber
nachzudenken und das war ein riesen
vorteil von dem ich auch mega in meinem
normalen arbeitsalltag profitiert habe
hinzu kommen die sachen zu machen die
gemacht werden müssen und mich nicht
ablenken lassen von irgendeiner social
media irgendwelche insta stories gucken
sondern ich wusste was ich zu tun habe
und ich habe die sachen einfach gemacht
und ich glaube das ist das was man bei
diesem projekt oder was ich bei diesem
projekt extrem gelernt haben tag 4 und 5
was super stressig für mich zum see zu
fahren das ist immer mit einer stunde
fahrt verbunden und da habe ich mich
dafür entschieden einfach kalt zu
duschen das hat im prinzip denselben
effekt dem inneren schweinehund
überwinden aber man muss eben nicht eine
stunde seines tages dafür opfern zum see
zu fahren und das ist vielleicht auch
das einzige problem was ich mit diesem
projekt hatte dass es vielleicht nicht
immer im alltag möglich ist
so geistesgestört kalt das ist einfach
noch so halb gefroren weil es jetzt
schon relativ spät morgens ist es schon
ein bisschen wieder angetaut aber es ist
wirklich kalt also ich muss schon sagen
heute ist wirklich unterdurchschnittlich
kalt viel kälter als die letzten tage
also so richtig richtig kalt und das ist
halt sehr anbinden was die sache nicht
besser macht wenn ich das aus dem wasser
kommen aber ich habe heute ein
vernünftiges thermometer mit um zu
checken wie kalt das wasser wirklich ist
außentemperatur heute sechster hat
wasser mit scheinbar ziemlich genau zehn
grad ist tatsächlich hätte ich gedacht
dass noch ein bisschen kälter ist also
zehn grad ist scheint mir gar nicht so
wenig aber es ist wirklich extrem kalt
es hat ist nicht vergleichbar mit zehn
grad außentemperatur verschiedenste
strategien sich abzuhärten ich bin auf
jeden fall nicht der einzige der mit dem
ziel ihn kommt heute ist der letzte tag
meines projektes ich habe mir extra ein
kameramann max mitgenommen der mich
begleitet muss wirklich sagen ich bin
happy dass es jetzt so langsam zu ende
geht
ich würde das niemals machen ja ja es
war wirklich hart war also so an tag 3
musste ich mich wirklich richtig
aufraffen in den see zu gehen aber genau
das war ja das worum es mir geht und
genau aus dem grund hat auch
funktioniert also ich habe es geschafft
gegen meinen inneren schweinehund so
übels krass anzukämpfen und auch nach
dem dritten tag immer noch weiter
eisbaden zu gehen aber ob ich das jetzt
täglich brauche irgendwie anderthalb
stunden eine stunde unterwegs zu sein um
mich für eine minute hier in so ein
eisbad einzusetzen weiß ich nicht am tag
4 und 5 habe ich ja nur kalt geduscht
also so richtig kalt dass jetzt gehe ich
aber als aller erstes mal wieder ins
wasser und dann sprechen wir uns noch ja
das ist auch wieder so ein problem heute
ist es wieder weg
wie ein paar der anderen tage auch also
tatsächlich habe ich das nicht sieben
tage am stück gemacht weil es einfach
arbeitsmäßig ein paar tagen nicht
geklappt habe insgesamt war ich jetzt
sieben tage aber halt überlegen die
anderthalb oder oder zwei wochen glaube
6 grad
der ist so wahnsinnig ist es wirklich
schon echt traurig das muss man sagen
also ende november anfang dezember sich
das anzutun
das ist so falsch aus dass jetzt
hinterleute macht diese vorbei wandern
und zu übrigens eingepackt sind sie
guckt so erwacht
das ist so falsch
das für falsch
und wie ist es so
bist du froh dass es vorbei ist
naja ich gegeben haben wirklich es war
eine tortur mich hierhin zu quellen und
in dieses eiskalte wasser zu gehen es
hat mir aber tatsächlich wirklich dabei
geholfen manche dinge einfach weg zu
schaffen und besser in meinen tag zu
integrieren das büro aufzuräumen mein
zimmer umzubauen irgendwelche kartons
weg zu bringen so so kleinkram zu machen
mit dem ich mich eigentlich mehrere
wochen auf halte bis ich ihn wirklich
erledige und ihnen immer von mir
herschiebe genau für solche sachen ist
es gut wenn man jeden morgen so über
seinen inneren schweinehund hinweggeht
dass man in sechs grad kaltes wasser
springt oder oder in zehn grad kaltes
wasser springt dann hat man auch kein
problem mehr damit ein mal eben wodurch
zu fegen kartons weg zu bringen oder
sich irgendwie für zwei stunden mit
ihnen das scheiß aufgabe zu beschäftigen
also in dem punkt was wo ich muss mich
leider kurz ist um sich fertig umgezogen
ob es aber jetzt meiner gesundheit dabei
hilft mein immunsystem zu stärken
weniger krank zu werden und so weiter
kann ich natürlich in sieben tagen nicht
komplett raus finden ich will es aber
auch nicht weitermachen um euch diese
antwort geben zu können laut wim hof und
anderen leuten die ich so machen ist es
möglich ich werde nicht weiter ins kalte
wasser springt es hat zwar spaß gemacht
aber ich habe gemerkt ich bin kein typ
der das jeden tag braucht und der jetzt
immer auch warme duschen verzichtet wenn
ich das video gefallen hat lassen wir
gerne like da vergesse ich den kanal zu
abonnieren
die jungen verpasst wir sehen uns am
sonntag maximiert